[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and the
mkbhd mouse game has not always been
strong but as a student and someone who
edits a lot of video i spend a lot of
time at the computer with a mouse so my
first real mouse wasn't all that special
just a pretty standard wired one but my
first real upgrade as with a lot of
other people i think was to the logitech
mx series so really popular with the mx
revolution and the performance mx and
these two were great i loved mine but
actually after a few months i got some
connection issues so i stopped using it
and went back to a different wired mouse
but now logitech is back with a
successor this one's aiming to fill the
shoes of the predecessor and then some
so of course i'm giving it a shot this
is the logitech mx master so right off
the bat this is a pretty good looking
mouse and i kind of have a feeling that
a sports car designer or something was
involved with this design i mean first
of all the commercials show a whole lot
of sculpting and chiseling of a model
mouse and i don't know if that happens
with every other mouse but i do know
that's exactly what happens with a lot
of sports cars and the mx master looks i
don't know kind of sporty in a way it
has a lot of the same looks as the
previous mx mouse with the righty shape
and the big sloping curves but at the
same time i've never seen a mouse that
looks quite like this with the little
rivets on the thumb rest and the big
arching spine it's actually a great size
and shape for someone with big hands
just like the performance mx was but
even if you don't have big hands it puts
your hand in a more ergonomic resting
position for better long-term comfort
and just you know people with bigger
hands require a bigger arch in the mouse
to make this happen which is why the
magic mouse is like the spawn of satan
but yeah the mx master aside from a few
design tweaks is very similar to the
performance mx that came before it
here's what's noticeably different first
the back and forward buttons they're
pretty small and they're supposed to be
in a pretty comfortable position above
the thumb rest but they're just a little
too far back for me so i had to adjust
my hand a bit when i wanted to use them
which slowed me down still getting used
to that i would have liked to see them a
little bit further up next to that side
scrolling wheel and speaking of the side
scrolling wheel it's back from the mx
revolution of two generations ago and it
is awesome i use it all the time it's
nice and smooth now it's a bit smaller
and i think it's easy to use you don't
really know how useful horizontal
scrolling is until you don't have it
anymore and i missed it big time i
actually use it most while video editing
and moving through my timeline in
premiere pro and after effects and stuff
like that so horizontal scrolling is
dope on the bottom of the mouse you'll
find the third new thing which is the
connectivity so this is a logitech mouse
so you can use the tiny logitech
wireless receiver we've all seen if your
computer doesn't have bluetooth but the
mouse also has built-in bluetooth 4.0 so
you'll have that choice my mac pro has
bluetooth so i just turned it on and it
connected within like five seconds no
problem and you'll see it has three
numbers on the back and a little button
that's because this mouse has a memory
and can live switch connecting between
three different devices at the same time
which can be really useful so i have
number one connected to my desktop
number two connects to my laptop and
number three is actually not occupied
yet so you can see it triggers the
pairing mode and it's blinking waiting
to add any third device but it's super
useful so i can see myself using this a
lot especially if you have a setup where
maybe you have two computers side by
side and you don't want to have two mice
on your desk or any other crazy software
solution to make that happen now it's
really useful you can use one mouse for
multiple computers so yeah other than
that it's all in the software with this
guy the new logitech option software is
the first thing you should download when
you get this mouse and it's actually
pretty good so most mouse software is
not that pretty doesn't work that well
but i don't mind this at all this is
where you set up the horizontal
scrolling and everything it also lets
you turn that thumb rest button yes
that's a button
into a gesture pad so you can hold it
down and swipe into mac os 10's gestures
and you can also adjust the smart
scrolling here so logitech is kind of
famous for this where if you scroll the
mouse wheel fast enough it'll stop
clicking and just initiate this super
smooth fast scrolling mode until it
slows down enough to go back to clicking
again so you can toggle how fast it
needs to do that or just disable it
completely there's also a nice little
battery indicator in the software now
the battery in this mouse is actually
sealed in which is a change from the
performance mx which had a removable
battery but i've had this thing for
about a week and haven't had to charge
it yet so i'm thinking it's probably
going to hold up to its claims of
several weeks of battery life with
normal use plus you can still plug it
into usb to charge it and continue using
it although i'm kind of surprised it's
not usb type c so overall logitech is
probably hoping this mx master becomes
the next legendary mouse that everyone
eventually moves to the next standard
and well i'm already on board and i know
a bunch of other people who make tech
videos who are already on board too so
it's off to a pretty good start i'd say
it's worth the 99 price tag on amazon
right now but i say definitely check
back at that link in the description if
you don't want to buy it now check back
in a couple of months it'll probably
start to drop like the performance mx
did so my mouse game is strong again and
hey maybe the keyboard game is next
thanks for watching guys and on to some
more important long-awaited reviews talk
to you guys in the next one
peace